this year marks the 25th anniversary
of judge judy the show are you kidding
me or what did you envision that the
show
would go this long i was only hoping
that we would last for two or three
years what
most things that have made for
television fail right out the gate
the public embraced what we were doing
well now judy is embracing the future
inspiring the next generation
with her contest you be the judge the
winner gets to rule her courtroom for
the day
this year judge judy picked anson north
a long time fan and college professor
from texas i'm the judge every day in my
classroom he's using
tools that he learned watching our
program
unfortunately you're not able to play
out your role as you being the judge for
the day
due to covet how would you have made
your mark
in that courtroom for the day i think i
would have made everyone laugh because
even when i get upset it's still funny i
actually have a message for you
from judge judy i would like to say to
anson that
watching and listening to you made me
feel as if the whole
25 years that i just spent doing judge
judy
was worth it i'm thankful for this
experience so thankful in my heart
we'll see you later